hey wassup guys my name is a channel
woged episode 45 of game programming so
first of all I've got a new Mac
microphone which actually literally cost
me less than half the price of my
previous one and you know it's it's
better like it sounds better in my
opinion so um that's kind of uh it's
kind of cool uh hum but yeah so if I
sound different that's why it's a
different microphone so um so yeah
alright anyway let's get started with
this so last time we talked about the
move method and actually finalizing I
guess the movement for the player and if
we launch the game apart from these
coordinates we also saw that the game
basically functioned as as it needed to
but we actually you know kept track of
the player's coordinates which was
pretty cool
now today we're gonna going to talk
about the player sprite so we don't
actually have a sprite for the player so
if I launch this what you are seeing
actually in reality let's just go ahead
and hide the coordinates if I go back to
game no Java in in the game class the
game that Java class I can I'll just get
rid of them let's get rid of this this
drawstring thing and alright so
basically what you're seeing is you know
essentially an invisible player in the
middle of the screen and the the map is
sort of scrolling with him I guess so
let's actually make him a sprite now
instead of going ahead and drawing a
sprite um I actually got an email a few
days ago from from Andy wall that was
his name so I'm shout out to him because
he actually like he actually drew a
sprite for me called qingchun oh and and
I don't mean I didn't even ask for it
like I just got an email and he's like
you know wrote me like a long message
about you know thanking me I guess my
tutorials and stuff like that and he
attached a qingchun oh so I mean that's
just freaking perfect
honestly like he just dashed it like
just as a present and and yeah and I
asked him if I could use it for series
he said yeah go ahead so um yeah we'll
be using this King Channel sprite which
is pretty cool actually so that kind of
you know takes the tasted
boring of it out of me so if we go to
our spreadsheet PNG file and I can find
it for you here if basically it's in
workspace is in your workspace and it is
in let me just find it alright so in
your rain directory in in the resources
folder in textures we made a file called
sprite sprite PNG which is what contains
our grasp right at the moment so over
here right what we're going to do here
is we're going to pop that sprite in now
you guys can make your own sprite if you
really want me to make it available for
download this thing I might um pop a
link in there or something with the next
next episode tomorrow but um as far as
this goes you guys can probably make
your own sprite but I here's a sprite so
I'll just pop it it is 16 by 16 sorry I
guess that would be 32 by 32 wouldn't it
hang on is it square
yeah be 32 by 32 so it is quite a large
sprite but we'll talk about that today
so I'll just pop it like I'm I actually
just pop it down at the very bottom just
because I don't know I might make it
into a 16 by 16 sprite in the future but
you know for now we'll just save what a
32 by 32 spry it looks like so here it
is in our game let's just um sorry in
our in paint.net in our sprite sheet dot
PNG file so I'm going to save that and
it's telling me to save as because
called multiple layers but I'll just
save it as a PNG again that's what it
was before just like that
oops save and I'll override it all right
sweet so and we'll flatten by the way
okay so now that we've got this King
Cherno sprite we kind of need to like
kind of needed draw it right so let's
start off with drawing this one right
here the top left one it's it's first of
all first thing we need to realize
realize honestly is that it's it's kind
of big right it's essentially four
sprites
it makes up for squares right it's got
four parts to it so back in the clips
here if we go into um into our sprite
Java class we can actually make it so
there's a few different techniques for
this I want to guide you through the
first one which is doing it in 16 size
chunks so we'll make a few sprites and
one of them is going to be called player
zero all right that's going to be like
the first part of the player we'll set
that equal to new sprite and it'll be
again sixteen size and over here I'll
have to find the x and y coordinates so
if we come down here we're at zero
that's one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so that's ten on Y and of
course your own X so that's what it's
going to look like and then obviously
it's using our sprite sheet for the
tiles so yeah I probably should have put
it into another sprite sheet but we'll
all organize that stuff later let's just
make sure this works first and obviously
duplicate that a bunch of times and
rename this three to one right so we've
got four different variables and as for
here player 1 will be you know this part
so it'll be ten foot one and then that
I've 1111 all right so four corners all
right I'm probably not gonna have time
to rush through this and explain
everything but you go you guys should
get this if you don't open up a thread
on write it the link is in the
description to my subreddit anyway so
now that we've got the four sprites we
also need to make the four ball we don't
even need to make the four things but if
we go back into player we kind of need a
kind of need a set of sprite here as
well so the way that I like to do this
is because player will be animated in
the future that's something you need to
consider right now we're not going to
animate it today but we will animate it
in the future obviously the way that you
could do it is you know the fact is that
this player class right now it extends
mob and mold only has access to one
sprite so that's that's an issue in
itself
we can sort of see through that if we
really have to so the way that I like to
do it is in the screen da Java class I
like to have a separate class for
rendering mobs or entering in the player
in this case so because because we kind
of do have four things to render because
we have four things to render it might
be a little bit difficult it'll be
different from the render tile method
obviously first of all it's going to be
different from the render style method
because completely different iteration
rendering but it's also going to be
different from mobs possibly and from
the standard rendering method because it
is twice as large so let's just
basically make something called 'rain a
player so it's going to have few
parameters I'm going to have in XP YP
and player player and it's going to have
the same rendering load let's just copy
this method render start method into
here and then we'll change it as we need
to so first of all we know that the size
of the player is 32 by 32
oh no we'll be doing it in chunks though
so 16 by 16 and let's import player this
stuff again I'll just you know make sure
that we're doing stuff the right way and
for here all I need to do is play our
dots oh but we weren't even moving in
our way so I'm sort of doing this on the
fly by the way um all right so they'll
be for different sprites so it'll be
whatever sprite would fit into it so I
guess better way would be sprite sprite
and then it would be sprite dot pixels
and then you know our standard X plus y
oops
plus y times oh yeah sprite dot size do
we have a well it's going to be sixteen
so as well put that in here all right so
that's going to give us our basic logic
here so if we come back into player
we've got a method here called render
and we can start feeding that stuff in
here first thing we need for Enda is the
screen
all right that's very important the
second thing we need is the actual
location of the render to be taking
place so the way that sort of happens is
you know because we're rendering we kind
of need we'll be rendering it at a
specific location obviously even though
even though you guys might think the
player sort of is in the middle of the
screen at all times that's a very bad
way to look at it because thing is like
you don't want to be like God doesn't
matter what where the player is
I'll just render them in the very center
of the screen yeah you could do that but
that's not cool like that's you don't do
it that way and I could of course give
you reasons for that one of the reasons
just off the top of my head is if you
want to like animated cutscene or some
or something that's running on the game
engine you want two offs you you might
not want basically you don't you might
not want to have the camera centered on
the player at all times all right you
might want to change that you might want
to make it so the camera is slightly
off-center like if the player is moving
really fast forward you might want to
just bring them back a little awesome I
love that bring him down a little
there's so many different things to do
it so you always want to be rendering it
at the location what you want to do is
set the location of the camera rather
than the location of the player to be
fixed all right sweet
so one thing we want to do is keep track
where the player is locally obviously in
the entity class we've got two integers
which keep track of where the player is
so over here in render we're just going
to simply go screen dot
Ren the player called the run player at
X Y so in other words words fitting that
stuff in and the sprite is going to be
interesting so the sprite at the moment
looks like it's going to be sprite
player zero now you guys might be
thinking but hang on a minute
you know while we're doing it this way
what happened to the rest of the players
rights and we'll deal with them in a
minute but first of all we need to
really talk about how this screen kind
of gets here so if we go back to the
place where it overrides we're
overriding screen which is wonderful but
we haven't actually ever made the screen
class visible in an entity before have
we and we kind of need to because if we
want to access the screen class in
player you know we need to fit it in
there but that's not really a problem
because we're going to do that from the
game class so right now our issue here
is the screen gives us a
nullpointerexception
and I'm sorry this episode is going to
be a little bit longer than usual but
there's a lot to cover here and I really
don't want to split up into two parts
because you guys all hate me for doing
that so yeah if we go back to our game
dot Java class Java I keep playing like
juvie
if we go back to our game dot Java class
you'll find that we had to our player
here and to render player we can simply
call in the render method after we
render the level player
render and then we can plug screen in
that way and now we've got the screen
thing so we've solved that null pointer
exception because it's feeding screen in
from here and over here screener is
actually equal to a new instance of that
class so that's all lovely and we're
probably going to work perfectly so that
gets rid of that and finally I think
let's just run it see what we get all
right look at that so we've got the this
this guy up here in the top left corner
of the of the screen that's that's
awesome so the first thing when you're
fixed is why xenon a lot in the middle
and the reason is not in the middle is
because we actually haven't given him an
offset to be at so what we've said right
now is
you know just be wherever we haven't
really been like you know be in the
middle so first thing you'll notice is
that like it is kind of working
perfectly in in a sense like it's doing
what we intended it to do is just not
set it's just not aligned that's all if
you check out X&Y
you'll see that that is actually worse
rendering them and as we move you know
it's it's still there it's like still in
the middle you don't man like the this
thing is actually moving along with the
player it's just over there so in other
words if we were to do something like X
plus the 300 and let's just say Y plus
20 right then you you know you'll see
that that doesn't work you know that
doesn't work so in other words you know
this is having an effect of where the
player is and at X and why it's working
perfectly let's jump back into our
render player thing and you can see that
that's sort of how we're playing around
with the offsets now we do have this set
offset thing the people keep talking
about that's kind of useful because you
know it lets us set the offset of the
player but what's happening right now is
that player is centered right it's
centered but it's off-center so what's
happening is as we divide the game as we
move this things moving along with the
camera which means that it's tracking
the location of the player which is
perfect so right now if we go back to
our game dot the Java class then if we
go down to our rendering thing we can
actually you know see that we're setting
player acts and player y at a particular
location so if we hit up the level dot
render you can see that the screen
offset is being set you know according
to player controls because we go back
here you can save play x and play it
always being set up that way but what we
really want to do here is actually I
guess offset their locations to be in
the middle of the screen so we can do
that with you know basically a few
simple math calculations so first of all
I'm just going to make
to integers just to make this a bit
easier I'm going to call the first one X
scroll so that'll that'll deal with the
actual horizontal position of the player
and we'll set we'll set X scroll equal
to player dot X minus screen dot width
divided by two so what that's doing is
basically putting it in the middle of
the screen
based on X right and then we'll also do
wasteful as well which obviously will be
exactly the same except player dot y
minus friend hi
/ - okay so it's getting it's getting
the location of the player and that is
subtracting a half of the width of the
screen which is putting it right into
the middle of the screen XY z-- and then
it's doing same thing into doing same
thing with y as well so if we substitute
these for X scroll and Y scroll our new
variables that we've made that of course
use play dogs and play dot Y which is
what we used before you'll see that now
check this out the player is the center
of attention so a few things I want to
just touch on first of all we haven't
noticed notice that we haven't actually
changed the location for this rather
we've changed the location of the map
the location of the map used to assume
that the player was in the top-left
corner right when we move the player
here we sort of move the map and that's
really cool so you can see how that sort
of works out to being now in the center
there's a few simple calculations that's
really how powerful this little set
offset thing that we've done is yeah
right now the players are sides of one
tile and it's they're still there's only
one quarter room so um so yeah we'll
figure out the rest of the three
quarters in the next video so I hope you
enjoyed this episode of game programming
let me know what you think about the new
microphone hopefully um my voice is even
more sexy with this thing but um until
then guys see you tomorrow later
[Music]
you
[Music]